why you
L and you
change and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so Civil War Frontline Issue Number 10
is one of the final two tie-ins of the
Civil War event and what we'll see is
that this event this comic book really
takes place before the events of Civil
War issue number seven but as it
progresses it will actually pick up
during the events of Civil War issue
number seven and what we see is that
Sally Floyd is meeting with Miss Marvel
and and that Miss Marvel has met with
Sally Floyd to Simply set the record
straight and what we learn here is that
Miss Marvel is actually the individual
the liazon for shield that has been
passing information to both Sally Floyd
and the NYPD and what we see is that
Miss Marvel confirms with Sally Floyd
that someone has been I guess maybe uh
involved on the inside with altering the
programming of Norman Osborne she says
that she has a record a condensed record
of the modifications that were made to
Norman Osborne's nanii controllers and
that she was helping Reed Richards
determine what time these n controllers
were activated and who it was that had
access to Norman Osborne during these
times in addition we get a flashback to
just after the meeting between Tony
Stark and Reed Richards about the
possibility of a traiter and the
identity of this traitor and what we see
is that Tony Stark informs his immediate
team that there is a traitor within
their midst and that after analyzing
Norman Osborne's samples before and
after he was uh detained and was
released that someone had made
modifications to this now initially the
question from Miss Marvel is who this
individual is but Tony Stark says that
they've identified who this individual
is but because of reasons of National
Security that Tony Stark can't tell them
from here we see that Hank Pim freaks
out and he begins to scream at Tony
Stark and tells Tony Stark that they've
been with him since the beginning and
that there's really no reason why why
Tony Stark should not be able to tell
them that Hank Pim feels like if anyone
has earned the trust of Tony Stark it's
been these immediate individuals that
have been with him and at his side since
the beginning of Civil War from here we
transitioned back to the meeting with
Sally Floyd and Miss Marvel and Miss
Marvel says that they didn't say who
this individual was that they didn't say
who the particular traitor was what we
also see is that Sally fooy begins to
sort of question what's going on here
she says it doesn't make sense why would
would Tony starkk and Reed Richards
confirm the existence of a traitor
within shield and then not tell anybody
who the traitor is and she goes as far
as to speculate whether or not it could
be Robert Reynolds the century and that
it wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
why would they even suggest that there
would be a reason for someone to
conspire with Norman Osborne Miss Marvel
says that there really isn't a reason
for this and she can't think of anybody
on their side that would conspire with
Norman Osborne but then says that she
has to leave in order to keep her cover
from being blown from here we see that
Sally Floyd looks at the envelope the
piece of paper that had been given to
her and is stunned to see that it is
really just that simple that this piece
of information has revealed to them or
revealed to her the person who was
behind the tampering of Norman Osborne's
nanites from here we see her contact Ben
urick and she says that she has stumbled
across a large piece of information
involving Tony Stark which of course
tells us that Tony Stark appears to have
been the person The Hidden Hand behind
the adjustment to Norman Osborne's
nanite programming but what we also see
is that Ben urick intends to tell Sally
Floyd about his findings involving the
Stark Market adjustments that have been
made and the financial gains that Tony
Sark has made since the beginning of the
Civil War event the two of them agree to
meet at Time Square by 6:00 but uh Ben
yuck adjusts this time and says that he
will meet her at 6:15 as there something
that he needs to do first from here we
see that Ben yuck arrives at The Daily
Bugle and interrupts an editorial
meeting between J Jonah Jameson and
Robbie Robertson and what we see is that
Ben urick tells J Jonah Jameson that he
has stumbled across what may very well
be the biggest story to have ever been
uncovered by anybody at the newspaper
but because of the fact that the Daily
Bugle is not set up for the potential
ramifications both legally and
financially for publishing this article
Ben urick is putting in his immediate
resignation he is quitting his job on
the spot and the reason for this is
because Ben yuck feels torn Ben yuck is
kind of in a position where he wants to
ensure this story gets published he
wants to ensure this story is put out
there or at the very least that the
information is made available but he
doesn't want to do it in a way that
would jeopardize The Daily Bugle
financially and legally and so we see
that Robbie Robertson attempts to
assuage uh Ben yuck from quitting but
then we see that jjon and Jamon cuts off
Robbie Robertson and tells him to be
quiet and then he tells everyone except
for Ben uck to leave once everybody's
out of the room we see that J Jon and
Jameson says he understands Ben's
position that Ben is a fine reporter and
that he understands when someone has
made up their mind from here we see that
Ben Yurick and J Jonah Jameson part ways
and J Jonah Jameson is sad to see that
benuck is leaving at this point we
transition back to Tony Stark and what
we see is that Tony Stark is watching a
news broadcast where the report is of a
swell a sort of upsurge in terms of the
mobilization of atlanteans along the
Atlantic coast but that there's no real
soner uh I guess no real way to
determine the size of this particular
force or just how much power this Force
has and the question that's being asked
here and the uh I guess the sort of
argument that's being produced here is
that Tony Stark has pushed the United
States towards a conflict with Atlantis
by virtue of allowing the Green Goblin
loose and then the Green Goblin engaging
in attacks against the atlantans and we
of course see that Reed Richards speaks
with Tony Stark for a minute and tells
Tony Stark that he had chose this road
he had chose this path and to stay the
course presuming that it'll probably all
work out in the end from here we switch
to Time Square at around 6:15 p.m. and
we see that Ben urick is meeting with
Sally Floyd and as the two of them are
getting I guess getting ready to
exchange information we then pick up
with the events of Civil War issue
number seven where the conflict between
Captain America's forces and and Iron
Man's forces has spread to the streets
of New York City and we see various
individuals such as Venom and Daredevil
as well as Radio Active man and others
engaging in conflict with one another we
see that there are virtual a multitude
of explosions in the background all
sorts of Damages being done and as a
result type face is presumed to have
been killed in the conflict we also see
that Ben urick and Sally Floyd head for
the subway station to sort of take
refuge against all the conflict and all
the action and the explosion explosions
that are going on and after the two of
them are able to catch their breath and
they are assuming they're in a safe
location they exchange information and
what they learn is that both of them
have come to the same conclusion and we
see that Ben urick tells uh Sally Floyd
that he believes that he knows the real
reasons behind the entire Civil War
event from here we transitioned to
Robbie Baldwin at a Cumberland Federal
Correctional Institute and what we see
here is that Robbie Baldwin is actually
meeting with the individual that had
shot him Robbie Baldwin's not being held
here and Robbie Baldwin has actually
been released but the individual that
had shot him is of course the father of
one of the children that have been
killed in Stanford Connecticut and
initially he's under the impression that
he's going to be questioned and he
demands an attorney but once he enters
the room he realized he's going to be
meeting with Robbie Baldwin from here we
see a great segment in the comic whereby
this father begins to scream at Robbie
Baldwin and tells Robbie Baldwin that
his wife had died years ago and the only
person he really had left in his life
was his daughter and now she's been
taken away from him and the only thing
he has left in his life is his hatred
for Robbie Baldwin but for the most part
Robbie Baldwin really has no sympathy
for this individual because the actions
of this man have led to led to Robbie
Baldwin being in a position where he
constantly has bullet shrapnel pressing
against the uh nerves in his spine and
so as a result he's in pain 24 hours a
day and so what we see is that Robbie
Baldwin meets with a man after burning
his costume burning his old speedball
costume and this man is presumably
building or has built a new suit for
Robbie Baldwin and this new suit is a
very grotesque and torturous looking uh
looking kind of suit this suit is filled
with a multitude of various spikes some
of which are longer than others and what
we see here is that the initial
impression on behalf of this individual
who has built this suit is that this
suit is going to be used to torture
someone this suit is going to be used to
inflict a massive amount of pain on
somebody else and when he asks who this
individual is supposed to be who this
individual is that Robbie Baldwin
intends to inflict so much pain on
Robbie Baldwin says that it's going to
be he himself from here the suit maker
decides that he doesn't want to have any
part of this he doesn't want to be
involved in this and Robbie Baldwin says
that either you can help me with this or
I can end your life and so this man ends
up helping Robbie Baldwin put the suit
on the suit itself actually has 612
spikes these spikes will dig directly
into the body of Robbie Baldwin and they
will cause extreme physical pain and 60
of these spikes are longer than the
other ones the 612 spikes represent the
total number of people who were killed
in Stanford Connecticut and the 60
spikes that are longer than the others
represent the 60 children that were
killed in Stanford Connecticut but what
we see is that as a result of this
extreme physical pain that Robbie
Baldwin has put himself through that
powers are now under his control telling
us that his powers only manifest when
his body is in extreme physical pain
when extreme external stimuli has really
kind of stimulated the powers that he
has developed so far and we see that
Robbie Baldwin changes his name and that
he's no longer considering himself to be
Robbie Baldwin he's no longer
considering himself to be speedball that
he has changed his name to
[Music]
penance so Civil War Frontline issue
number 11 brings an end to the main
Civil War conflict that is to say the
events that have been bubbling up to the
ultimate conflict between Captain
America and Iron Man and the way this
story is told I would go as far as to
say makes it one of the absolute best
stories ever told in Marvel Comics and
probably one of the best comic books
that I've ever read in Marvel Comics The
Story picks up after the events of the
conflict the fight between Captain
America's forces and Iron Man's forces
and the surrender of Captain America and
the story is told from the perspective
again of Sally Floyd and Ben urick and
what we see here is that after the
events over after after everything is
all said and done that everybody begins
to come out of hiding all the normal
civilians all the UN unpowered
individuals come out of hiding and
attempt to figure out what all is going
on and then we see the total devastation
that was wrot at the hands of these
superheroes as they engaged in this
final battle of the Civil War and what
we see is that for the most part a large
portion of Manhattan is devastated it's
not necessarily totally obliterated but
there's enough damage to be going on
with and from here we switch back to
listening to either Sally Floyd or Ben
Yurick describe what's going on here
describe this perspective the view of
these events from the perspective of
your normal average everyday person and
the reality here the understanding and I
guess the uh decision that people have
come to is that something has to change
something needs to be done here that all
this conflict really did is underscore
the necessity for the Superhuman
registration act it was to underscore
the need for superhumans to somehow not
necessarily have their personal
identities made public but for there to
be some way that superheroes have to be
held accountable because this very
instance could very well Mark the
beginning of a much darker future for
the world that if superheroes are
allowed to remain unchecked if those
individuals who remain uh underground as
part of the anti-registration movement
continue to come into conflict with
those who are in support of the Civil uh
superhuman registration then it's going
to produce more conflicts just like
these it's going to produce more
problems just like these in addition we
see that either Sally FL or Ben Yuri is
talking to us about how when Captain
America had surrendered that either
Superheroes Were rounded up the
remaining Superheroes Were rounded up by
shield and Iron Man's forces or they
simply ran away way and we see that for
the most part history as she says it
will say that people dodged the bullet
that the American citizenry and even the
PE the world as a whole had dodged a
bullet by Captain America effectively
surrendering by the Civil War conflict
coming to an end but Sally Floyd says
that there was really no time to ponder
this concept there was really no time to
think about this because they were too
busy trying to put out fires too busy
trying to focus on uh getting problems
remedied giving getting the situation or
the city back to a state of normaly to
really focus on exactly how it is that
future Generations will view the results
of this Civil War conflict what we also
learn here is that the death toll of the
fight in Manhattan was 53 people and
only six of them were superpowered
people now this is extremely important
when it comes to the Civil War conflict
because for the most most part both
sides at least for the the brunt of the
conflict were fighting on behalf of what
they thought was right but throughout
the entire Civil War conflict there was
very little I guess recognition or very
little Credence given to the necessity
of ensuring that normal human stayed
safe and we saw this throughout the
entire conflict we saw this as things
progressed as things became more and
more serious from the time that Nitro
self- detonated and destroyed a big
portion of Stanford Connecticut to the
time that we ended this Civil War
conflict we never really saw a lot of
discussion on how is this going to
affect the average person how does the
average person view this we knew that a
majority of people sided with superhuman
registration but for the most part the
story focused on the superheroes and
that in and of itself is really the
defining aspect really the defining
point of the mindset of those who were
leading the Superhuman and the anti-s
Superhuman registration movement from
here we see that Sally Floyd and Ben
Yurick are at the raft at Riker's Island
and of course as we had previously
discussed the raft is the location where
they keep superpowered uh individuals in
order to I guess provide an
form of I guess either security or maybe
just detainment for these individuals
and what we see here is that for the
most
part Captain America's not that upset
he's not that sorry about his stance
regarding the Civil War event he
recognizes that there are some things
that he could have done different he
recognizes that there was a possibility
that he could have met with Tony Stark
and other individuals to really kind of
find a peaceful uh altercation this a
peaceful resolution to this entire Civil
War event but instead instead he went
headstrong and decided to fight on the
side of freedom but for Captain America
he feels as though he fought the right
fight he apologizes over the fact that
there was so much damage done and that
to a degree the perception of him and
other superheroes may very well have
been betrayed as far as their actions go
and how they're viewed by Humanity but
at the end of the day he still stands
staunch as a supporter of freedom and
believes that he was fighting on the
right side from here we see that Sally
Floyd has had enough and Sally Floyd
absolutely let Steve Rogers have it and
this I would say points out the inherent
flaw the fundamental issue with Steve
Rogers fighting in the 20 21st century
despite the fact that he was discovered
in the 1960s and a majority of his
experience regarding worldwide conflict
and War took place during World War II
Sally Floyd says that Captain America
has no real understanding of what
America is about that he doesn't
understand what America is she asked him
if he knows what Myspace is because at
the time of Civil War space was still a
relatively popular form of social media
and Captain America says he doesn't
understand what this line of questioning
has to do with anything she's Sally
Floyd says she understands that but ask
Captain America to bear with her she
asked him who won the World Series last
year or who won American Idol last year
and Captain America is not able to
understand any of these questions or at
the very least he's not able to answer
any of these questions and this is the
flaw that Sally Floyd points out that
Captain America despite the fact that he
argues to be on behalf of Freedom that
he argues to be on the behalf of the
American citizenry doesn't really know
anything about America and this again is
the inherent flaw of Captain America
Captain America was a World War II era
fighter he was a fantastic Soldier and
he was a great Beacon of freedom in the
world at the time but from the 1960s
when Captain America was rediscovered up
until this current Point Captain America
never moved on Captain America never got
over the fact that things had changed
when Captain America was fighting in
World War II and even then during the
early days when he first reappeared in
Marvel Comics villains for the most part
were very basic they were very
unimportant regards to uh with regards
to the world as a whole in terms of what
it is they wanted to achieve very rarely
did you ever find villains that were
willing to go to the extreme in order to
achieve their goals periodically you
would but most villains for the most
part were very simple and they were very
basic and they were very comedic and
this is Marvel's way of telling us that
these days are gone that these things
are passed if you recall our discussion
on Ultron we had talked about how the
masters of evil was really kind of being
betrayed as this Antiquated form of
villainy in Marvel Comics this really
touches on that yet again that Captain
America holds himself to an ideology
that is no longer existent that the days
are gone when super villains are
effectively bank robbers when super
villains are attempting to carry out
these laughable goals that super
villains now are extreme that super
villains now are willing to kill people
kill multitudes of people in order to
achieve their goals in addition Sally
Floyd talks about how in this day and
age you have superheroes that are far
beyond the capabilities of anything that
Captain America is capable of doing that
you have superheroes that are so
powerful that they are a threat to not
just the planet Earth but the universe
as a whole and that maybe just maybe the
necessity for a superhuman registration
Act was there that if anything the
conflict between Captain America and
Iron Man proved that there is a
necessity for some form of superhuman
registration because a superhuman are
allowed to fight one another and they
are allowed to engage in Conflict like
this with this kind of Destruction then
what would future Generations do what
kind of lawlessness would the world be
looking at if there's no way to hold
superheroes accountable for their
actions from here we see that Ben Yu and
Sally Floyd leave Captain America to his
thoughts and Ben Yurick is a little
surprised to see the cap that Sally
Floyd had taken the stance as she did
that she had been so harsh on Captain
America but Sally Floyd's not very
apologetic for it and feels as though
the these were words that Captain
America needed to hear that either
Captain America can step into the 21st
century or he's he's going to become a
relic he's going to become this uh
symbol of an Antiquated time in humanity
that doesn't really apply to society
anymore from here we get this sort of
montage and what we had seen was that
Sally Floyd and Ben New York were going
to meet with Iron Man 10 days after
their meeting with Captain America and
it was a chance for them to gather their
information and to present the uh their
findings to Tony Stark and over the
course of this 10 days we learned that
yuck and Sally Floyd had of course quit
their positions with their respective
newspapers and they had started their
own news reporting agency called front
lines.com we of course see that Dany and
Sally Floyd are together we see that um
the century Robert Reynolds comes out in
support of superhuman registration but
we also see that Ben Yurick and Sally
Floyd still maintain contact with those
individuals who are underground with
those individuals that are doing what
they can to I guess maybe circumvent the
goals of the pro registration move
movement what we also see is that for
the most part Society is trying to get
things cleaned up Society is trying to
piece things together but we also
learned that there has been about a 38%
increase in the number of people who
have chosen to register and the reason
for this is because the United States is
teetering on the edge of war with the
atlanteans because the atlantans have
not forgotten the actions of Norman
Osborne at the loading docks the
atlanteans had not forgotten the actions
of nitro in Stanford Connecticut despite
the fact that Justice had been served on
Nitro regarding the fact that he had
killed Ney Marita we see of course that
things are still a little shaky that
things are still a little rough that the
amount of security that's being imposed
on society as a whole is something more
than people had ever expected despite
the fact that it's being imposed on both
superheroes uh villains and normal
people we also see of course that uh
some of the superheroes various
individuals gather to uh offer their
condolences and offer their well wishes
to those who were killed in the Civil
War conflict and are passing on from
here we see that Sally Floyd and Ben
Yuri are meeting with Tony Stark and of
course they state that they have a
meeting with Tony Stark when they when
they arrive at um at Tony's residence
but we also see that Ben Yurick tells
Sally Floyd to Simply stay quiet that
Sally Floyd doesn't need to go on the
kind of tiate and the kind of rant that
she had gone on when they had met with
Captain America now what we see here is
effectively a piecing together the
puzzle coming together regarding the
actions of Tony Stark during Civil War
because we knew that Tony Stark had
engaged in some rather unsavory actions
by the time Civil War issue number seven
came around but we didn't know how all
this fit together we didn't know exactly
what it was that he was doing or what
the end result of all this was now what
we see is that when Ben YK and Sally
Floyd are meeting with Tony Stark Tony
Stark says that they are welcome to ask
him whatever they want that he has
nothing to hide and Ben Yurick tells
Tony Stark to remember that he said that
and Sally Floyd begins with a recap of
these Civil War events Sally Floyd of
course tells us that 612 people were
killed in the incident in Stanford
Connecticut and that as a result a
dubious law a dubious bill was proposed
towards proposed to Congress and it was
passed almost overnight and that
individuals that were in violation of
this law were haed off and they were
thrown into the Negative Zone with
extremely harsh conditions despite the
fact that so so little time had passed
that a lot of these superheroes who were
debating the merits of the law really
had no time to debate it properly they
effectively had to either de side with
it or go against it and there was no
real chance to argue the merits of
whether or not this law was appropriate
what we also see is her telling telling
us that the pro-registration leaders of
the Superhuman Community had gone with
releasing various super villains and
intended to use these super villains as
a means to track down uh superheroes who
had refused to register and that some of
these super villains specifically Norman
Osborne had somehow gone Rogue and that
they had basically committed actions in
effect attacking the atlantans and put
the United States on par with almost
going to war with the atlantans had
really set us down the path to the brink
of war with a whole different culture
she goes as far as to say that you
wouldn't think it could get any worse
but that Sally Floyd and Ben YK have
uncovered the fact that there is a
traitor within the shield organization
now Tony Stark really tries to jump on
this and say that there will always be
wild exaggerations and rumors but Ben
Yurick stops him and says that they have
documented proof they have a schematic
that indicates that there was a
re-engineered a presence of
re-engineered nanites in the blood of
Norman Osborne and that it was put there
by person or Persons Unknown effectively
telling us that someone had altered the
nanites and Norman Osborne's body to
allow him to operate outside of the
parameters that had been specified for
all super villains that were working as
part of the Thunderbolts under Shield
what we see is Norman I'm sorry Sally
Floyd and benuck asking why someone
would do that why would someone allow
thems or Ally themselves with someone as
unstable as Norman Osborne and then
allow Norman Osborne to effectively go
Rogue and act within his own accordance
what we see is that Tony Stark says that
uh this is wrong that there will always
be superheroes there will always be
super villains rather that will attempt
to go Rogue but they will never be
successful that for the most part the
super villains will always be under
control of shield and then we see that
Ben urick says that he agrees with Tony
Stark that he believes that Tony Stark
is right here and he says the biggest
misdirection is the one that hides in
plain sight he says the Green Goblin had
never left the control of Tony Stark
that Tony Stark himself is the traitor
and this is when we get the explanation
of what was going on with the Green
Goblin Ben urick goes on to say that the
most obvious question was why a man with
Osborne's physical strength would make
his way or make use a pistol I'm sorry
as a means to assassinate or attempt to
assassinate a member of the Atlantean
delegation because a pistol would really
not do anything to damage an Atlantean
the Atlantean physiology is such that
they are far beyond what a normal human
is able to do they are more durable they
are stronger they're faster and so it
wouldn't make any sense that Norman
Osborne would choose to use a pistol to
attack an Atlantean in addition we see
how Norman Osborne having Supreme
physical strength well beyond a normal
person was subdued by the police and
again this doesn't make any sense that
Norman Osborne could have easily
overpowered the police now what we also
see is Ben Yurick talking about how when
uh I guess Norman Osborne was being
interviewed by Donna and Keith who of
course were the detectives that we were
following during the story of Joe that
every time he tried to tell them what
was going on every time he tried to tell
them that someone was controlling him he
would begin foaming at the mouth and he
would be unable to do so and then we get
the pieces put together we get the
pieces established for us and we
understand what it was that Tony Stark
was doing that the actions of nitro in
effect causing the incident at Stanford
Connecticut set off a chain reaction and
this Chain Reaction would mean that
somewhere along the line somewhere later
on down the line that eventually people
would come into into conflict that the
superhero Community would be split and
the only way to really uh stop this the
only way to really keep this from
happening was to initiate the entire
Civil War event uh by means of setting
up the Superhuman registration act
forcing superhumans to register now Tony
Stark not expect that there was going to
be so much uh anti- I guess anti-
registration sentiment on behalf of
various superheroes and so to counter
for this he released Norman Osborne and
adjusted the programming of Norman
Osborne's nanites with Norman Osborne's
nanites programming adjusted Norman
Osborne would now be controlled by Tony
Stark Tony Stark had Norman Osborne
attacked the atlantans by virtue of the
atlanteans being attacked the atlantans
would threatened war against the
superhero community and the United
States as a whole and so in response to
this both uh normal humans and the
superhumans with regards to the idea of
being of going to war with the atlantans
would band together for a common goal
and it would effectively end the Civil
War now of course Sally Floyd says that
in a very sarcastic way that she thinks
that he did what he did for the greater
good that she applauds him for his
actions but of course Tony Stark
realizes this is she's being sarcastic
and he tells her to leave now this is a
very important part of the Civil War
event and the reason why is because the
actions of Tony Stark may be looked at
by some people as questionable they may
be looked at by some people as outright
heinous that he effectively manipulated
all the events of the Civil War in order
to basically ban the superhero Community
together against a common cause by
almost bringing the the United States as
a whole to Brink with Atlantis to the to
war with Atlantis Tony Stark didn't know
if it was going to happen Tony Stark
took a gamble here Tony Stark rolled ice
had Norman Osborne attack the atlantans
and then hoped the atlanteans wouldn't
immediately attack the United States and
go to war with us and so we see that
with with Tony Stark here depending on
how you view him as an individual
depending on what your moral compass is
you may say that he's right that he made
the right decision here he took what was
in effect a fractured superhero
community and banded the superhero
Community together against an external
cause he took this perception of
humanity view of superheroes and managed
to eliminate this for a moment while
everyone banded together against a
single cause but then you could look at
Tony Stark and say that Tony Stark is a
manipulator that Tony Stark manipulated
circumstances that there's no real
justification for his actions now from
here of course we see that Sally Floyd
and Ben urick leave and they informed
Tony Stark that they are not going to
make this this public they are not going
to tell anybody what's going on and this
is really an intelligent move on their
behalf and the reason why is because if
this information got out if if people
learned that the end result of the
Superhuman movement the Superhuman
registration act came to what it was
because Tony Stark had manipulated
everything people would lose Faith
people wouldn't believe that they had
actually banded together for a good
cause they would look at the C the
current circumstances as a result of
manipulation and they would walk away
from this ideology of working together
which of course would most likely set
the superhero Community right back down
the path of open Civil War but also
leave the United States open and and I
guess um Poss possibly being able to be
conquered by the atlantans if we the
United States as a whole went to war
with the atlanteans Tony Stark feels
guilt-ridden as a result of this he
recognizes that so much Destruction has
been wrought that billions of dollars
worth of damage have been inflicted on
uh Manhattan as well as various other
cities around the United States that 50
some odd people are now dead all because
he had manipulated things and
effectively done what he did uh for the
greater good from here we see that the
comic book comes to an end and we're
left with this idea with this question
in our heads of did Tony Stark actually
do the right thing and from here we
bring an end to the story of civil war
with that being said I hope you guys
enjoyed this whole Civil War series I
had a great time putting it together and
uh if you guys have any suggestions any
criticisms anything things you guys
would like me to do in order to I guess
maybe look at things from a different
perspective or when it comes to Future
story lines to make changes and feel
free to let me know and I will catch you
guys later
[Music]
peace